when you think of the word nuclear what
comes to mind it's probably some
terrifying thought I can't blame anyone
for being nervous it's a technology that
we've been using for decades that can
really reduce global warming but it's
not exactly something environmentalists
are that excited about the first thing
many people think of is nuclear war and
mushroom clouds you add into that major
events like Three Mile Island and
Chernobyl and most recently Fukushima
and those have had incredibly profound
consequences on people's immediate
feelings and images and associations
with this technology this isn't
something where the public has the view
wrong it is a technology with a
reputation that's been earned
I mean if a nuclear power plant was
being built in my town I'd be pretty
nervous about it however as a
conservationist that makes me feel
really conflicted because these power
plants don't emit co2 and that's the
main pollutant that's causing climate
change when you look at the technology
and you ask yourself how are we going to
solve this problem of climate change to
not have nuclear energy be on the table
makes the job much harder now for the
most part these plants work really well
they supply about 20% of the electricity
on the u.s. power grid but almost all of
them in the US were built over 35 years
ago in fact they look like something out
of a vintage movie set and historically
they've had two big problems they
produce radioactive nuclear waste and
they can be vulnerable to a disaster
like a nuclear meltdown nuclear
meltdowns happened because water that
used to cool the radioactive fuel rods
can't be pumped in usually due to
something like a backup power failure
this fuel heats up rapidly and since
these reactors operate at high pressure
that can be explosions from all this
excess heat you can think of it like a
balloon popping and releasing the air
inside but in this case radioactive air
Lesley Diwan is trying to fix this she
runs a startup company called trance
atomic power they're trying to build new
power plants without this problem our
reactors operate at atmospheric pressure
and you don't need that typical
containment dome you don't need the big
stacks you have a lot more flexibility
in the architecture of the plan and that
low pressure also means that there's no
way to have a nuclear balloon pop
scenario but it isn't just about
stopping disasters fuel itself is toxic
and has to be stored underground for
thousands of years and unfortunately we
don't use it very efficiently the solid
fuel can only stay in the reactor for a
limited amount of time before it starts
to break itself down and you have to
physically remove it you can only
extract about 4% of the energy that you
could conceivably get out of the uranium
and the rest is left behind is waste
this is like opening up a bottle of
water taking a sip and then tossing it
out
that's actually how older reactors use
nuclear fuel the next-generation
reactors are using fuel much more
efficiently transit omics reactor design
will use fuel in a liquid form so that
it can stay in the reactor for a longer
period of time a lot of the advanced
nuclear reactors can consume much more
of the energy from the uranium you can
get much much higher fuel utilization
which means that you're leaving
significantly less waste behind and this
is a trend in the field there's a huge
interest to phase out conventional fuel
rods for different forms of fuel for a
variety of reasons in the last 20 or 30
years we've developed different types of
fuel which cannot melt and which in fact
what do you mean by that physically
cannot know that's Pere Peterson he's a
nuclear engineer at the University of
California Berkeley who's working on a
next-generation reactor design that uses
an entirely different form of fuel many
older plants still use conventional fuel
rods this new design known as a fuel
pebbel in cases uranium in a golf
ball-sized sphere it's made of a very
strong ceramic material that can
withstand much higher temperatures so it
cannot melt and it's safer to use now
this one was built to demonstrate that
you could fabricate it so it does not
have uranium in it but in every other
way it is identical to the real thing
same weight and everything right and
they're designed to be to be very safe
you can drop this thing from 10 meters
onto a steel plate and it won't break or
if I wanted to I could drop it right now
and so essentially that fuel pebble is
designed to be its own self-contained
system if a power failure does happen
the pebbles just empty into a holding
tank where they cool down on their own
no need for backup generators or water
to keep it cool to prevent a meltdown
okay so why hasn't this happen yet I
mean we have better materials we have
reactors with new designs and fuels that
make less waste it actually sounds like
we have the answers to our problems so
what's the
you know the old phrase you never get a
second chance to make a first impression
people's first impression of nuclear
energy and nuclear power was mushroom
clouds and as it's got the word nuclear
associated with it it's just going to be
very difficult to convince people no no
we mean it this time
this one's safe it puts nuclear energy
in a very challenging place right now
even solar and wind are cheaper than
nuclear power so there isn't a lot of
economic incentive to build these power
plants and if no one wants to build them
then companies that make the parts go
out of business or go somewhere else
where new plants are being built like
China those that are under construction
now the economics have been really grim
the number of plants that have been
started and the price overruns have been
massive one of the problems is just
simply transporting the components
instead of getting the parts locally
like we did in the 1960s and 70s the
parts today are shipped from overseas
and these aren't just basic nuts and
bolts these are huge complicated
components if a section of a reactor
vessel breaks during transport it needs
to be fixed or a new one needs to be
built and reshaped taking more time and
money to complete I think that it's
going to be very interesting to see how
startup companies tackle those problems
and this is a very different space from
where the traditional technology evolved
now rapid innovation has happened in
other industries look at SpaceX for
example they went from a concept rocket
to delivering supplies to the
International Space Station in a matter
of years the technologies that are being
researched now that look very promising
range from small modular reactors where
the whole nuclear power plant comes in
the back of a flatbed truck gets parked
plugged in and when the fuel is used up
simply gets taken away as unit to be
reprocessed these small modular reactors
could have specific uses like powering a
data center that's using electricity
around the clock we have startups
building cheaper smaller reactors that
don't melt down we have
engineers making fuel that doesn't
produce much waste while the public
image of nuclear energy is rooted in the
past the nucleon og of today is a whole
different ballgame people like me view
nuclear as being a necessary piece of
carbon free energy production there's
less of that fear of nuclear and more of
sort of a need to use everything in our
toolbox to combat climate change there
are other energy sources that we may be
overlooking for example scientists are
actually turning to poop to power cars
head over to climate dot University of
California ddu for more